hi there steve kaufman here today i am
going to tell you why i don't learn
languages
um
and this thought came to me as i'm
proceeding with my arabic learning and
it suddenly dawned on me that you know
i'm not really learning arabic
i'm discovering arabic or arabic is
really revealing itself to me gradually
very gradually
so let me explain so
i have talked about
in language learning the sort of
upside down hockey stick where there's a
very steep climb at the beginning where
you start to
all of a sudden you can say a few things
you understand a few things you feel
good about yourself
and then that's very steep and tough but
then you get to a level now where you
you realize that in order to really
become comfortable in the language
there's this long
shaft which isn't climbing so steeply
where you're just going to have to keep
going keep going keep going in order to
learn the language
acquire the language
and i've also talked about three stages
that initial stage
which is kind of the steep shaft
where
everything is noise
you know nothing in the language makes
sense and then you quickly get a sense
some sense of how the language works
word order how they ask questions
whether there are tenses
how verbs change or nouns change so you
get a sense of all this stuff
you're aware that these things happen in
the language yet you can't really
remember it you can't produce it but
you're able to make sense of things to
some extent
uh and that's sort of the first stage
the second stage is you are now starting
to explore the language through
interesting content because in that
initial stage whether it's the steep
hockey stick or trying to get used to
how the language works that's where you
deal with beginner content that's where
i deal with these repetitive mini
stories that i've talked about that i
learned in link and that's whole that
whole sort of
getting some sense of how the language
works
but then once you've completed that
first stage now the second stage you're
going through now interesting content
but struggling because you can't
understand it
uh you know
when you're away from it or if you don't
have the text in front of you so you're
still deliberately working to acquire
the language
and uh you know typically again on our
uh new word or unknown word counted link
i mean that
25 to 50
new words i mean working it down now in
arabic i'm about 25 30 percent
new words
uh but still
and i'll explain what i'm doing in in
arabic but i'm nowhere near where i want
to be because when that third and final
stage which i liken to the cross-country
skier is just you know
gliding through the forest enjoying the
scenery enjoying the exercise that's
where
you know i uh
you know got to say in ukrainian where i
could listen to an audiobook on the
history of ukraine and understand what
they're saying read it to pick up a few
words and phrases but i'm basically now
fully independent in the language
and
my feeling is that until i achieve that
third level of independence in the
language in terms of comprehension
until i have that base i will never be
able to speak well
so
with that as a sort of preamble let's
get back to where i am in arabic i've
had quite a few conversations with my
arabic tutor ibrahim i struggle mightily
i forget the same words i make the same
mistakes i mean arabic verbs in the
present tense if it's ah you know if it
like
you is too hebu
he is you heboo
all these changes that yeah i know them
in theory but to try to produce them
while i'm speaking in a conversation is
more difficult so i struggle
and until i've had so much exposure to
the language
including the ability to just
listen to the language and understand 50
60 70 of it so that it's gradually
creating habits in my brain i don't
think i'll ever be able to converse
comfortably so because i have an hour to
a day to spend i have to choose how i
spend my time so if i spend an hour
speaking with a tutor online that's an
hour that i'm not
picking away at words and phrases and
reading and listening so that's a choice
if i have seven hours a day
and if i have unlimited funds as when i
was a
language student for the canadian
government then i can have three hours
of one-on-one being drilled you know
getting better at producing the little
bit that i know
while then spending the rest of the day
acquiring more words and more
familiarity with the language but i
don't have that luxury right now so
what i am doing now i feel that i've you
know i'm at a stage where i can with
great difficulty speak
sort of i could work harder on the many
stories to improve my ability to produce
what i
have you know what i have acquired
or
i can spend more time
discovering the language letting the
language reveal itself to me and i find
that that's what i find more enjoyable
now
i'm tired of the mini stories i don't
want to occasionally go and do one just
to get you know if i'm going to have a
discussion it sort of refreshes my sense
of the structures of the language
but i know that those benefits are short
term
on the other hand
uh what i'm now doing is i go to
websites like websites like al jazeera
or deutsche bella or franz van cat
another one which i was given by
actually an uber driver here in palm
springs
is alhurah.com
and i
using our chrome extension i
bring all those um
articles from al jazeera or whatever
interlink where i go through it i'm
looking up every third word now there's
sort of a mixture of of words that i
have acquired words that are yellow in
other words i'm in the process of
acquiring them and words that are blue
in other words words that i have never
seen before
and i work my way through these but it
is interesting because i am gaining a
different perspective on the news for
example uh a minor thing
uh this uh
saudi journalist who was murdered in the
turkish in turkish temple
uh who is called khashoggi
is actually
so i know how to pronounce it
uh but i also get the perspective
from various arab capitals
uh the perspective on uh the killing on
donald trump
on um
this uh
the saudi crown prince how he's viewed
it
by the journalists union in tunisia
in egypt
so it's all fascinating and then i have
the al jazeera podcast and they also
talk about the same subjects
unfortunately i don't have a matching
transcript to podcast i haven't found it
on any of the sites not franz madcat not
al jazeera not
so i'm but i'm still learning so much
because
uh
they're talking about politics they're
talking about uh
middle eastern politics then alhur has
more social articles about
you know women's rights in the arab
world and stuff like that so i'm
acquiring a range of vocabulary although
it is good i find to focus on one area
like
this
saudi crown prince murder of
hashiti khashoggi in istanbul if i read
three or four articles on that and then
i listen to podcast discussion you know
people debating that then i'm starting
to get a certain concentrated doses of
the dosage of some of the same
vocabulary but it's also fun to explore
but the point is
i know that the language will gradually
reveal itself like a jigsaw puzzle
and right now i struggle
i go through picking word after word and
and gradually recognizing words that i
you know converted from blue to yellow
and i see them again in yellow and i
don't know what they mean
and i'll see them again and again and
but i know that
it is my interest in the subject matter
that is driving me to read through these
and i'm mostly enjoying the process of
gaining these different perspectives on
on events around the world
and yet when i listen to the podcast i
don't understand very much
but i know that gradually
that i will not understand less and less
i will understand more and more more and
more of these words will stick
and so and and once i get to the point
where i'm independent of the text where
i can truly understand what i hear
then i know
that it won't be long before i can speak
because once i have that kind of a
increasing familiarity with the language
once the language has revealed itself to
me
then i'll start to be able to speak and
of course in arabic for example with the
verbs in the present tense there are
different endings depending on whether
it's
you he
uh she
they
they male female to they like two of
them or many and in theory i've looked
at these tables and i can't remember
them but if i start to hear them more
and more often in context then they
start to become natural i'll start to be
able to use some of them correctly when
i speak uh can use the un and now for
they kind of
sometimes
uh but if i have enough of this
sort of built up
sense of the what's the language much
the jigsaw puzzle is more complete than
getting to where i can speak
well and comfortably is not such a big
issue and
so that's my goal is not so much to
learn arabic but to find ways to have
the language reveal itself to me so that
i acquire the language
and
you know i can enjoy listening to al
jazeera podcasts
for years
uh how often i'll actually have an
opportunity to run into someone with
whom i can speak
uh fusa
or for that matter uh fusa is is modern
standard arabic or even a dialect of
arabic should i be in that situation you
know those opportunities are are fewer
whereas the opportunity to continue
to to listen to al jazeera to read their
articles
uh
to hear you know panel discussions about
subjects it's just added now an
additional perspective uh on the world
for me and so that's why i say that
at least my strategy now we can all have
different goals if the person's goal is
to be able to produce the language
quickly then obviously if you can be
drilled three hours a day one-on-one
you're going to get to where you can
produce some of the language quickly
but
it depends on what our goals are uh i i
know people who can speak couldn't
maintain a conversation but i remember
once i had i knew this uh
couple swedish couple who in france and
they were very francophile and
and uh
you know i gave the lady an audiobook
french audiobook i said you should
listen to these wonderful you know
novels
in in french while this audiobook and
she said i can't understand audiobooks
so i don't want to get to the point
where i can say some things in the
language but then when i hear audio
naturally spoken audio uh not
necessarily people talking to me but
people talking with each other or people
in a movie and then i can't understand
it
that's not where i want to get to so
a bit of a ramble
on this concept and i guess it gets back
to stephen krashen we don't learn a
language we acquire a language we
acquire a language through exposure
through
deliberately encouraging the language to
reveal itself to us which is exactly
what i'm now doing with arabic and i'm
confident that it may take me a year but
i will eventually get to that stage
where i can listen to material without
reading it and i'll understand most of
it so thank you for listening i hope
that makes some sense i look forward to
your comments
oh and one thing more i almost forgot we
have our annual sales we had a
link we had a black friday sale we
launched on friday and today we have our
cyber monday sales
and essentially you can get a full year
at link
and instead of it costing you 120 it'll
only cost you 99
and if you're serious about learning a
language
acquiring a language discovering a
language
it's going to take you at least a year
so
there it is have a look see if that's
something that is of interest to you
and um i look forward to seeing you
again here or at link bye for now
[Music]